is it possible
i apologize this is a really dumb
question but is it possible to
that proof will come out that p equals
np
but an algorithm that makes p equals np
is impossible to find um is that like
crazy
okay well well if p equals np it would
mean that there is such an algorithm
that it exists yeah but um um
you know it would it would mean that it
exists now you know in practice
normally the way that we would prove
anything like that would be by finding
the algorithm by finding
one algorithm but there is such a thing
as a non-constructive proof
that an algorithm exists you know this
has really only reared its head
i think a few times in the history of
our field right
but you know it is it is theoretically
possible
that that that that such a thing could
happen
but you know there are so even here
there are some amusing observations that
one could make
so there is this famous observation of
leonid levin
who is you know one of the original
discoverers of np
completeness right and he said well
consider the following algorithm
that like i i guarantee will solve the
np problems efficiently
just as provided that p equals np okay
here is what it does it just runs you
know it enumerates every possible
algorithm
in a gigantic infinite list yeah right
from like in like alphabetical order
right
you know and many of them maybe won't
even compile so we just ignore those
okay but now
we just you know run the first algorithm
then we run the second algorithm we run
the first
one a little bit more then we run the
first three algorithms for a while we
run the first four for a while
this is called dovetailing by the way
this is a known trick in um
theoretical computer science okay but we
do it in such a way that
you know whatever is the algorithm out
there in
in uh in our list that solves
np-complete you know the np
problems efficiently will eventually hit
that one
right and now the key is that whenever
we hit that one
you know it you know by assumption it
has to solve the problem
that's to find the solution and once it
claims to find a solution then we can
check that ourself
right because these are increasing
problems yeah then we can check it
now this is utterly impractical right
you know you'd have to do this enormous
exhaustive search among all the
algorithms but from a certain
theoretical standpoint
that is merely a constant pre-factor
that's merely a multiplier of your
running time so there are tricks like
that one can do to say that
in some sense the algorithm would have
to be uh constructive
but you know in in in the human sense
you know it is possible that
to you know it's conceivable that one
could prove such a thing
uh via a non-constructive method is is
that likely i don't think so
first no no no not personally
you